Gilbert welcome in oh well thank you
of course thank you I saw you tinkling
in the men's room
Oh were you watching Gilbert well I saw
his backpack I didn't know it was him I
saw the backpack and you can't look at
the face yeah why can't you look at the
face it's tingling yeah I don't want to
see somebody's pissing in a men's room
I generally good manners not to like
lean over great I would have grabs you
by the shoulders and shook you with
happiness yeah you try to avoid eye
contact yeah like if someone's taking
you [ __ ] you don't go over and give him
a big push
you kneel down you hug their wife
someone I got a bathroom etiquette
question real quick I was in the [ __ ]
a couple weeks ago there was a guy in
the stall next to me guy peeing at the
urinal sneezed the guy in the stall next
to me said bless you do you get involved
with people sneezes when you're taking a
[ __ ] do you bless somebody from this
firm stall now yet when you're in the
stall you have to act like you're not
even yeah yeah that's weird right if
you're the Pope someone has talked to
the Pope all he was [ __ ] big white
trousers around his ankles question yes
I'll marry you see the Hat you don't
know if it'll be a cross burning we need
an answer Pope we need an answer we need
yeah your holiness
you're the tell-tale sounds of an old
man [ __ ] it really does humanize him
it really that humanizes everybody yeah
you had shitty lights that smoking thing
[Laughter]
I thought it was so eloquent I can't
remember who said it but somebody said
you know I don't I don't get intimidated
by people aren't getting intimidated
meeting everybody everybody shits yeah
that's true you could just picture them
squatting over a bowl and [ __ ] that
is
whatever full said that is lying sure
you do oh you meant not everybody sheds
oh or some famous people you can't
imagine [ __ ] with a pope until today
yeah it's good I can't anyone you don't
really necessarily want to picture it I
can picture any of them sitting but you
can't picture any of them struggling the
strain the struggle or the type will you
have to [ __ ] like dab the back of
your thighs in your ass cheeks
I want my heros to have a nice release a
nice big taper or one wipe yeah you
don't want to have them gone yeah it's
splatter I think it's the legends like a
Dolly Parton would be a tough one
yeah it's a picture dropping a deuce it
would be no I could see her yeah I
wouldn't have a trouble sing dolly
pardon you thinking because of the the
big breasts would lead to big show yeah
I see I get another picture her [ __ ]
but me laying under it yeah I don't know
I feel like Jennifer Aniston tries to
market herself is like kind of the every
girl like ah she's just a cool chick and
you know what cool chicks do yeah she's
the girl next door next door the girl is
shame yeah that'll be the that will be
the ultimate celebrity video leaked when
you get like some a-list celebrity
taking a [ __ ] on a paper plate for her
boyfriend yeah there's got to be one now
Anne Hathaway her taking this [ __ ] she's
so luxurious no you would think that
that would be okay no I got it it took
me a second but I got there yeah I
haven't before still think she looks
great [ __ ] not at all points yes
it's a solid movement even eight inches
I picture her [ __ ] hits the water like a
Chinese high diver no splash
just [ __ ] tens across the board a nice
juicy periscope disappearing grace
whispering you know Gilbert you would
actually be able to provide some insight
I don't know if this has ever happened
to you but we were having a conversation
I don't know if it was over this week or
last week where one of us I won't say
who I don't embarrass anybody one of us
woke up after sharding in the bed and
there was a there was a liquid residue
between the cheeks I don't want men none
on the bed okay
not on the bed would you ever wake up
with any kind of defecation problem in
the bed I I think I've been lucky so you
[ __ ] and I bet I did but it didn't go on
the bed it stay between my cheeks I felt
like I taken a small sip of coffee must
hold you between my lips that's like
that well with with our deadline
yeah happen he one time our party laying
I couldn't picture not Shane that when
he's awake mistaken for the toilet
mattress
Artie Lange sold his toilet because he
was [ __ ] in the beds anyway just a
waste of space
some people do [ __ ] their pants
occasionally whoo I didn't accident this
weekend oh this week and told me a break
I said Tammy for the air boy that silent
moment was like out of a mystery yeah I
think killer is in this room
Colonel Mustard had the flu and got
drunk if she was passing the study show
it was Colonel Mustard this weekend is
mustard in his pants did you as a grown
man how does that happen
well I was back home in Pennsylvania a
little shoo fly pie
I went to a place called yonkos they
have great hot dogs had two hot dogs had
a cheese steak pierogies and then I had
Popeyes after cheat day yeah this is a
great commercial boy I I said hot dog so
great and I took a [ __ ] you have a
friend in Pennsylvania for somebody that
just got their tits done you're grown
back you eating like that seems like
you're just like sweet it's a waste of
money it's an embarrassment of riches
you have that you could you're gonna
have to go back and get your tits done
again I know yeah
so you had a boob job so he had like
mantequilla advantages and he had tagged
and that bad that he had a half yes yes
but he had ice put on them and that
compressed his breast no I wasn't I it
was a full-on
yeah like a cop job is what they're
called yeah Dolly Parton yeah exactly
what cup are you now better they were
actually they were actually able to fill
up enough for Dolly Parton's next boob
job they put Troy's tip hat into rose so
wait how much did you shitty urinal you
know you let a little far down as a boy
so I was like oh is it just a fart no I
went into the stall yeah I took toilet
paper and literally could scoop it did
not touch my underwear that's not
amazing when you [ __ ] win it with
your cheeks it just goes to the brim and
stops discovery show life you deep into
your 40s I had a lot of grease but don't
you don't you think it did you have a
moment where you were like you know I
really got I was gonna say I got to
start getting my [ __ ] together but
that's probably appropriate phrase no it
sounds like to meet your grippers are
shot brother like you got no grip back
there because he doesn't know how to
piss and fart at the same time it's it's
so easy once in a while a little liquid
does slip out I've had those moments if
you have you and Troy may have the same
problem where you put enough up back up
there and eventually the elasticity
starts to wear I mean I can't argue yeah
both you got an e-zpass my spine hurts
ever [ __ ] have I or no Julia Rob about
Julia Roberts what do you think lightly
of yourself wow you know a junior Robert
yeah junior that's right Julia Roberts
she did while she was doing her winning
smile and laugh finger Roberts laugh I
think it was just she did it once and it
was to get in character because Erin
Brockovich did so she had to Erin
Brockovich was a well-known hand [ __ ]
so Julia Roberts had to do it as well
I'd love to see her panty collection and
just to know that there's a [ __ ]
Brown dot in the back and a crimson in
the front of every pair of pants really
humanizes a person doesn't it yeah
crimson and brown we're all the same man
we all [ __ ] we all get crimson stains
yes there's a picture of it in US
magazine with the title she shits in her
pants she's just like and they show like
a collage of all of her panties in a
half circle with two dots in each one
there's one really bad ones the flu pair
on the end you and your construction
truck you can relate
what about kiss when they're wearing
those big do you love kiss Jim I've
learned those big metal Cod pieces do
you think they've ever [ __ ] their pants
and have to take off those metal
underwear I don't mind what's under
there I doubt gene and Paul hat but I
when they're on stage maybe ace has
probably and [ __ ] his pants yeah he's
too much of a rock star he's too much of
a rock star to not have [ __ ] his pants
he would [ __ ] and announce it yeah he'd
miss a verse what happened what what's
his name from
Mick Jagger Richards Ronnie's rich
charlie means richard bill Tetley
heckler I could see Keith Richards
inking in his pants all during the day I
can see Keith Richards doing it just
because he didn't want to get offstage
like I'm purpose I'm gonna take a [ __ ]
right Oh fer key one-time Nike Peter in
our pen oh she's pissed all over it
that's so hot I love the the artistic
commitment it takes a chance while she's
doing jumping jacks on my chest
awesome
yeah because you know she's wearing
shorts oh there's a photo a very famous
photo of Ferg and she's got piss all
over her pants but she's wearing shorts
which means while she was onstage
there was a nice piss stream coming out
her short life Wow yeah Jim standing
over it like it's a rainy day that
reminds me I love it so yeah Fergie
Peter pants yes great I just like the
idea of a performer whether it's a
musician or communion or whoever it is
committing so much to the act that
they're pissing and [ __ ] themselves
on stage because they're there to give
it all to the audience Larry Hooper
should himself once you know know what
oh happy day pretty good song actually
yeah
the Sun is shinin Oh looking at the
wrong camera by the way his hair is
perfect the flesh colors I can't get it
under the chair in the background the
terrible columns this is the greatest
performance I've ever seen hey I killed
my mother would you mind skinning her
and making a suit out of ha ha
he is the best are we in the West or
Rome
and Texas they have a lot of columns you
see guy bleed time it's like it's
outside what show is this lawrence welk
I believe it is like this
Gilbert is this your style this is very
exciting yeah pink suit [ __ ] it's good
[ __ ] all right
I can't I can't I just want to hear that
over I'm fine I'm happy with this look
of course Gilbert by the way has all
kinds of stuff there's the documentary
out that's on Hulu iTunes YouTube Google
Play Amazon Video on Demand DVD blu-ray
there's the amazing colossal podcast
you're gonna be at Caroline's is that
right yeah yeah I don't know I just
gotta check Gilbert Gottfried comm are
you doing a full weekend there just one
I think just one night yeah just the one
night I know if you remember Gil where I
did a Caroline show with you open for
you I was backstage with you and your
wife and a friend of your what you guys
had just had your first child and the
friend of your wife's came by with a
gift she had made a blanket for you guys
oh yes and and she held it up as free
rude she got your wife Gilbert look how
nice a killer goes Oh an AIDS quilt
Gilbert is also uh he's on cameo and you
know we like you to the shoutouts we
like to watch the cameo videos on the
show and we also we rank celebrities
based on how much they charge for their
cameos and how you know how hard up they
are and I'm gonna tell you something
Gilbert Godfried he has more integrity
than most with his cameos I'm gonna
guess Gilbert charges 50 a shot that's
my guess captain Gilbert I have it on
good information is it one hundred and
fifty dollars
yes for cameos see I I have a feeling a
lot of the people who do it are like hey
hey hey great yeah hey Bill have
anti-scratch me yeah yeah and it's like
they're too cool right to do it right
yeah hey shout out and then that's it
now do you do you worry at all Brett
Favre
got in trouble oh because yeah they
snuck in anti-semitic remarks do you
worry that somebody's gonna catch you
saying something inappropriate
that was funny it was like like that
American Nazi Party I think if the check
clears Gilbert is pretty good with it
every year if they pay me enough
so at 150 they don't need to sneak the
message in you can see on the paper I'll
say it I see yeah could you spell 3
second video of the overcoat
show me your paper do you want to watch
one you bet I do
all right let's jeez let's see the one
Gilbert did from Heather yeah already
she's got her money's worth
hi see that bad would have been I bet
you there are some celebrities who just
do that go hi right right but they don't
even have even this late they don't have
a distinct voice they don't have
anything it's just like yeah they'll say
say hello to my cousin bill hey Bill I
like the urine now this is smart though
cuz you're killing time in the video by
going hi this is Gilbert got everyone
knows your voice you're announcing it so
it's cute killing four seconds there's
no actual time limit doing no I know but
you're still getting a little extra
value I should take a sip of coffee in
between you know you should do turn the
camera on before you're even sitting
down slide in like Tom Cruise and risky
business just hear my footsteps first I
built the little pitter-patter just
Gilbert do it Foley word gonna flash to
Heather and it's from John Lindbergh
John says tell Heather happy Valentine's
Day we've been together for four years
and I've never given you a gift
four years and he never spent money on
you boy Heather you are my kind of girl
drop this John and God clicked me
never spend time on you anyway John says
I love you so much and I'm not but you
are the one that is so pretty I hope
this one makes you smile and I look for
many many more and yeah Heather give me
a call that's good see you know it's
done
oh you camera stayed on for a little
while it sounds like I'm someone who's
first learning to work with a cue card
it is what it and I wasn't I didn't
either
thank you and you're breaking the fourth
wall John says enter stage left
[Laughter]
he says cautiously now Gilbert I don't
know I'm assuming you did not watch the
Grammy Awards did you no no no did you
see the trailer for Aladdin I know I
heard this like a whole controversy
Aladdin the Bryan Singer story yeah you
know will Will Smith is catching a whole
bunch of [ __ ] because he looks really
bad they're doing a live action version
of Aladdin and Will Smith looks horrible
as the genie were you contacted at all
no no they don't want you playing Iago
I'm sorry it's a matter of fact like the
plays been on Broadway for I don't know
how many years and when it opened I
thought oh for sure they're gonna invite
me for the big opening didn't invite me
did they get the Affleck the new F on
stage they honored him is this after the
a polite thing they didn't invite you to
the play no didn't invite me and then I
remember after about a year I called him
and I said I call as theer and I said hi
I'm Gilbert Gottfried I'd wanted enough
I could get seats to see Ellen and they
said well
rush the street down oh yeah they we in
the afternoon they haven't fair price
they wanted to send you to TK - yes -
you yeah you Gilbert can't call the box
office and go you have a manager or
somebody quite now and that's that
something else I realized that I think
you're pranking is that if you have
somebody else call also it makes you
sound Lorne
hoarse hi I'm Gilbert can I have a
ticket no one's gonna say come down I
don't know it's really high this is the
parrot from Aladdin can I have a ticket
for the play hi I'm Indiana Jones some
manager called the manager of the place
and go hey I'm good what about that
we'll get it done yeah course I will I
remember I I went there was some party
at the Playboy Mansion
so I called and I said it's Gilbert
Gottfried I'd like to see if I can get
invited and and they said oh we're not
open to the public
I gotta have someone else call yeah yeah
we're not open to the public it's always
it's always I mean it's already an
exercise in like figuring out where you
rank when you have to call and say can I
have an invitation yes because they
could easily say like if you could have
an invitation
you'd have you would have we invited you
would have been invited five years and
in fact sounds like they did know it was
you because they told you where the
tickets were at half price
yeah I was hoping that so when's the
prom with Will Smith I don't know
the CGI is horrible Smith looks bad it
was very believable be glad Robin
Williams isn't in it this is the old
trailer Troy we would need the new
trailer yeah I says October 11 I get to
get it staged yeah I was kind of hoping
after they showed
so yes you see how his face doesn't
really fit the head it looks like a bad
porn parody of avatar yes yes just like
those porn parodies they see I see this
right and in my head I'm going maybe the
plan is they're just gonna take Gilbert
they're just gonna find a full-size
parrot suit and there's gonna have him
running around and doing the parent suit
thing or have me on a crane flooding for
anything at this point yeah but nothing
huh no that's garbage that's garbage
almost is garbage
one person we do pay and that was my
favorite he said if Gilbert Gottfried's
not in the current alight and I can't be
held responsible for what I do in the
theater so if he shoots up a theater
uh-huh it'll be in my name and you know
and you're honored yes yes partly you'll
be in the next one yeah did you ever get
this I'll be in every movie for me did
you ever see the play uh oh yeah you got
to go yes
- how'd you get in ah five kts he went
to the boot I snuck in did you meet the
cast oh yeah well I must I love you
you're in the original yeah yeah very
exciting yeah yeah I I will yeah yeah I
don't know I had nothing else to say
that's okay you know when you start
talking you have nothing it's like and
then I am then I go wait I have nothing
you're really hoping something would hit
you halfway through the second yeah oh
no didn't come night after night yeah
Hey ladies and gentlemen I I really
didn't have a joke right I don't know
why we're here yeah are there any
environments Gilbert that make you
uncomfortable to do comedy and because I
feel like you are just ready for any I
was watching uh bumping mics yeah and it
was just like it seemed like any time
they looked over at you you're like oh
you want another joke here's 50 and
you're just ready to go at a moment's
notice is that the way I mean are
there any environments where you didn't
just be ready to disgust everybody yeah
I don't know I I can't think of hand but
I know there are those times where you
sitting there going oh well how many
times do you sit there and go ah gee I'm
doing a bad imitation of myself right
now right we start I'm doing I'm doing
Gilbert I've already I'm that guy I
sometimes I'll be doing something and
I'll feel like like these people have
come up to me on the street and
imitating me and I feel like you know
they're they're about as good as I am
like do you get hecklers at your shows
and do you ever have to deal with it
because I've worked with you but I've
never seen you you don't not now like
you know I used to I used to get there
you suck it off the stage which I used
to yeah sometimes you'll have people
scream stuff out but then if you answer
them and that gets a life then the
heckler thinks oh I got a while now
right I'm helping
I'll say things like hey people paid to
see me not you yeah I do that probably
nailed him every time keep it down to a
dull roar my grandmother would say that
whenever I was talking too loud grandma
was pretty for an old woman she was very
gassy she really was yes yeah she had
she told me to keep it down to a dull
roar because she was in bed and I had a
bullhorn and I was yelling she was fart
on all the car rides I smelled like she
was but she wasn't she had a catalytic
converter problem in me poor escort I
asked her she was farting and she said
no it was too literally the catalytic
converter I feel like I could fart in
any situation and blame it yeah hurt her
like we're in the kitchen Lionel
you know Gilbert you're a family man now
yeah and something that you might not
know you know you hope that the kids
grow up to honor your legacy and their
kids grow up to honor and everything and
something you might not know about Jim
that I've always loved about Jim is that
after his grandmother passed away uh he
brought a actually a lady of the night
down to his late grandmother's room and
she was pregnant right she was young and
the pregnant prostitute sat in his dead
grandmother's room and smoked she smoked
while he's up she said am i and my
friend penis this is by 1986 something
normal in this story yeah that's my 88
so she sucked my penis and then went to
my grandmother's living room area and I
could hear something I smelled it I'm
like that's crap
I smelled it but guess what it's what
Nana would have wanted she really was
but didn't you go to some hooker one
time one time and no no I mean this one
particular and there was also a guy
there and it's like they were gonna like
pounce on you or something I said you
went there it was a dark deserted world
oh that was on Second Avenue you doesn't
look at you at first like what are you
talking about Gilbert and then when you
said dark deserted room he's like Oh
second is how you separate no Kay was
this on the corner we I thought he was
looking at you going like this story
makes no sense to me in reality he's
looking at you going this could be any
number of it's the location type of
bridge if doing the Terminator scan
ahead of all the perverted moments I
remember this one no I remember this one
I thought of this with like within the
last couple days it flashed it in my
head I went to see her she was like a
girl for like massagers I don't remember
it was and I walked in this place it was
a go railroad apartment it was really
dark and I looked in the bathroom and it
was water in the tub with like Burger
King wrappers and fruit flies it looked
really nothing no she's holding a
screwdriver so I handed her money
she went to the front door and like
opened and handed it to somebody else
outside and we just sat there and the
back of the apartment was dark and I
thought I heard movement and in my mind
I'm like something very bad is gonna
happen
I got a tremendous premonition of
something bad happening like my every
instinct is like just go get out right
and I stood up and I'm like hey I'm
gonna leave I think I lied I'm like I've
cancer I have to go and I thought yeah I
left and I was shaken by that it was a
crazy instinct that I listen to and I
felt column that nighttime I just was
bad I was shaking it's like something
[ __ ] horrible is gonna happen yeah I
don't know if that's instinct or just
clear logic like there is no way that
that scenario ends well right yeah
something because she was holding that
screwdriver and it was a weird energy it
was an energy thing and like I just was
like just go you didn't well that maybe
she was a carpenter nurse she was
christ-like so maybe yeah Bernie gets
role play did you go back the next night
companion did you like catch crepes from
the same girl ice yeah when I was like I
was maybe 18 yes my father would say a
lazy man does everything twice father
was right and I knew it was her the
second time I wasn't 100% sure and the
second time right after I looked down
and where's Little Rascals [ __ ]
rappelling down one of my [ __ ] long
pubes you got to the bottom of it huh
yep yep that's why I saw pubes Gilbert
you never went through a prostitute
phase did you all right no no that I'd
have to pay yeah I was thinking that
didn't have as much to do with honor as
it did the book yeah yeah you know if
there was like you know like a
whorehouse that was giving out free
coupons doesn't want to pay for food
yeah my first time working with it House
of Blues in Las Vegas I've heard him for
years I couldn't wait he was like the
first big comic guy I was ever gonna
work with I get to the House of Blues
I'm like I'm gonna pick his brain about
this someone asking about that he said
two words to me and then I just watched
him walk
the green room and steal every continent
that was available and put it in his
body and I just go oh my god he's legit
he's the real deal yeah yeah did you
when you when you watch the the
documentary and they portrayed you is
somebody who is not maybe maybe you
don't enjoy spending money and quite as
much as the next person
yeah we're called Jews did you feel like
oh I don't like the way I was portrayed
as much or did you go it's about time
people realized I like to I like to keep
what's mine and take what's yours
oh well watching that watching the
documentary to me it's like you know
that first time you hear yourself
recorded or you see yourself and you
know oh god that's not me
yeah and that that's like watching the
documentary what do you say you still
save all those like shampoos oh yeah use
them yes yeah I used him I love that he
go ahead he watches the documentary he
goes no that's not me and then he
continues to do everything he did like
it doesn't stop and and I'm watching
myself I felt like I thought I walked
like Greg Fox and Sanford Gilbert the
only guy who gets wanded leaving the
show have you ever been caught stealing
anything embarrassing from yes he has
Artie Lange show what happen I forget
what they call you taking it was like a
coffee maker
when Nixon followed already has a show
on Direct TV right from the greenroom
they were like yeah Gilbert was there he
took the coffee maker they had to make
him like they caught him you still
nicked Apollo and Artemis coffee maker
they were starting from the back not the
coffee maker some coffee
whoever was it was they they would they
caught him and then God yeah it was a
problem coffee if I could slip it under
my jacket I would have taken it away
that's what they paid with yeah fun gig
you did that show buddy yeah I love that
a giant studio a to Solarize man but I
remember at that show besides Bocchetti
being the announcers all these pretzels
yeah those [ __ ] you know those [ __ ]
flat it looks like a pretzel has been
sliced
yeah the best that they were great you
miss doing the RT and Nick show for the
pretzels yes I do I see I say that's
pretty good insight about the legacy of
a show it was just so much fun you'd sit
there and I hope one day people go oh I
miss doing Jim and Sam because the
intern used to bring us coffee they had
a box of tissues on the test how we
really missed this yeah yeah yeah yeah
nobody was looking you go home with the
whole box no problem they had a water
fountain not the end of the hallway the
toilet had those little square papers
like high schools square toilet papers
so do you do you strategize your meals
meaning when you go to a show do you go
like okay no I'm not gonna eat before
the show absolute because they're gonna
give me a free meal and I'm gonna eat
more than I actually wanted I'm not
hungry after and you know what I hate
too is if I get two offers for a free
meal in one day then I feel like oh one
rules out the other I see yeah it's you
want it you want to you want to eat
enough for the first free meal that it's
gonna last you all day
exactly and I'd rather have the second
meal tomorrow yes for free tomorrow yeah
that makes sense to me you also have to
factor in him missing an opportunity for
yet another free meal is gonna burn him
up all [ __ ] down tonight and we'll
get you upset is your wife like this -
yeah no no no she's she'll eat this you
want to pay for a meal right you don't
like that yeah do you know what she's
one of those that one of those do you
guys are you one of those that put your
hand in your pocket and takes out a
dollar frustrating if you're out like
you she wants to go out and eat and
you're like I want to just stay here Wow
sure and then it's yeah it's it's it's
it's kind of like I guess it yes the way
of describing the Gentiles and he's one
of those people who pays fresh meal if
you're going on shiksa
are you a big tipper
oh I I don't know I never know what to
do that's like a scary thing do you tip
drivers Oh Oh sometimes something you
know what that means no no but I don't
want to say that on the radio
wouldn't let's say you get like an uber
eats or something like that
what do burn overeats do now is they'll
come up after the thing gets delivered
and and the whole transaction is over a
thing will come up on your screen going
I hope you enjoyed your whatever service
drive or meal would you like to tip the
driver what option would you take two
four six or no thanks well if it wasn't
if my name is attached to it pressure I
see but it's anonymous anonymous I mean
oh go [ __ ] the guy over in a shake
everyone knows you yeah what's the
biggest tip you've ever given some oh I
don't know hmm if I if I left that yeah
but you ever done a five-spot ah white
$5 you see the clutches chest what am I
rockefeller when you go on vacation with
your family will you pay for first-class
airfare I mean you've been in show
business for so long you have would you
pay for first-class airfare enough and a
five-star hotel I not a first-class a
couple of times we've I've used maybe
miles - sure but you know the funny
thing is I remember in the old days of
Airlines I would get on I'd have a coach
ticket and back then oh yeah you know if
they answer yes they recognize you they
go oh here let me see if there's
something and they would never do that
to your eyes now they can't dates all on
a computer yeah so would you just go to
the airport every time wearing a problem
child t-shirt boarding the plane parrot
there were a couple of times I've done
this where I walk past the first-class
and then I'd act like play stupid and it
just has like I wanted some information
about the place right and and then if
they recognize me they go oh why don't
you come but that forget it all right
no now you could be a member of the
first class club and now pulled you out
yeah yeah do you do you worry sometimes
that when you're sitting in coach people
will go that's the big celebrity Gilbert
Godfrey what's he doing in coach oh sure
don't you want to maintain a certain
image of yourself no no not if I could
save a dollar right not less free yeah I
see I see
do you so you don't you do you and your
wife eat separately she'll go to a place
where you have to pay and you'll make
yourself a young man joke yeah maybe my
wife have a romantic dinner every week
she goes home Wednesday I go on Thursday
but will you will you at least allow her
without giving her a hard time
yes or do you give her a hard time I'll
give her a hard time you will okay okay
I also picture give it as a guy who's
totally fine with sitting in the middle
seat on the flight no middle oh god
you're I've sat in the middle of you
that's pretty horrible it sucks it's the
word that is torture do you check your
seat before the plane like before you
fly do you ask for as if exceed oh yeah
I used to UM oh god I remember there was
one ant well this was one of the TV
shows flying me out there was one
airline that had what everybody referred
to as the Captain Kirk see the middle
seat was American Airlines first class
cross country that yes yeah and on that
you it was it was two on the left one
middle two on the right I think it would
be a single person meaning yes there's
one rose that was great hey I said
behind our sharpton once he was in the
first middle seat and I was in the
second middle seat and I just watched
him sleep for the whole flight Oh grab
me one time I was in the middle seat and
I was sitting behind Kiefer Sutherland
Oh
was right after Kiefer Sutherland like
Julia Roberts like didn't show up at the
wedding
she was [ __ ] at home yeah I mean and
this is a 100% true
the stewardess is handing out earphones
and she says the Kiefer Sutherland will
you be watching the movie today and he
said watch the movie and I swear to god
she said Julia Roberts and runaway bride
no and he he surprisingly said no no
that that was 100% that that middle seat
on that American flight was so [ __ ]
great it was like Captain Kirk the way
you sits in that big seat yeah with the
big armrest right in the center nobody
bothers you no one to the left or you
could jump out each aisle to pissed up
to you yeah yeah what do you do what do
you do with your offspring Gilmore
because Julia Roberts about oh [ __ ]
everybody knows let it go [ __ ] yeah you
get [ __ ] in the rug you know children
can be very very expensive yes not all
you know if the Gilbert not only for
their schooling but also for their
recreation there's always there's a new
toy there's this there's that they want
to whatever
are you are you chintzy with with with
your offspring as well or is that a
different scene now now that's something
that's seen now it's I remember when I
was a kid there were these things these
toys they advertised on TV and I thought
I'll never have one of those right yeah
like my parents would never get me were
they cheap yeah well they they you know
they didn't have that much money
they didn't it was like I yeah and you
know what get this I always think about
my parents when I think of coming yeah
jerking off fingering my it's like mom
and dad are both here I think of my dead
cranberry always think when I complain
I've got jobs I have like you know doing
a club or whatever and then I think wow
you know like my father actually got his
hands dirty right yeah your [ __ ] but
so what do you do I mean you have money
unlike your parents when your kids say I
want something you got to give it you
yeah yeah yeah cuz they don't or I might
put them up for adoption okay or try to
sell them like like an Oliver Twist made
a couple bucks off of it hi this is
Gilbert guy solid my kid
seat now now the imitation he just did
there sometimes when I'm when I'm on
stage or you know when they feel it the
most where when I'm at some event and
like a reporter will put a mic in my
face I'm I feel like I have to say
something funny right right and you're
like what's the Gilbert Godfried voice
again I said um your voice yeah and so
your imitation just now I felt like I
you know that's funnier than me very not
funny going onstage I do you ever get
this feeling on stage are they sometimes
when you're out there in the middle of
it all of a sudden it comes into your
head and you say what the [ __ ] am i
doing right now it's like it's a bunch
of people looking at me and I'm standing
here it's the auto plant sometimes I'll
be like am I here right now like it
doesn't feel like I mean even in there
yeah like I'm lightheaded and I'm
somewhere else and I'm like just keep
talking this is real this is happening
yes yes you ever just look at and then
in your head you're like I fooled all
these people yeah actually
well I mean
I'm good at this I felt that way my
entire career it's like like I always
feel like show business I snuck into
it's a party that I snuck into right and
one day they're gonna look at the guest
list and see I'm not invited I'm just
constantly waiting for that metaphorical
bouncer like you're just looking over
your shoulder at all times yeah every
bothered by heckler because they're like
you suck you go you don't like me I hate
me yeah you've just known me for three
minutes you know me my [ __ ] lie
you're right that's why I'm called my
new CD fooling you the insanity yeah